voici l'homme le plus recherché des
Philippines le commandant bravo chef
militaire de la rébellion islamiste est
traqué nuit et jour par 1800000 soldats
sa tête a été mise à prix 5 millions de
dollars pour le trouver nous sommes
allés sur l'île de Mindanao dans le sud
des Philippines plus exactement à
maraoui surnommé par ses habitants la
perle de l'Islam en ville aucun étranger
même les militaires Philippins ne s'y
aventurent pas trop dangereux ici la
population est à 100 % musulmane c'est
le lieu idéal pour trouver quelqu'un
pouvant nous mener au commandant bravo à
maraoui les manifestations
antigouvernementales sont quotidiennes
les catholiques au pouvoir à Manille
sont accusés de génocide et considérés
comme une force
d'occupation nous exprimons ici notre
désaccord avec le gouvernement
philippin nous la nouvelle génération
nous sommes les plus forts nous devons
nous battre
au cœur de la manifestation nous
rencontr Ariel un jeune islamiste il
connaî bravo et dit être de ses hommes
il peut nous présenter d'autres
combattants comme
lui rendez-vous est pris pour le soir
même nous nous retrouvons discrètement
dans une maison un peu à l'écart une
diain d'étudiants nous attendent pour
passer le temps il regardent des
cassettes de la Guer
Chechen
une
embuscade ou ouis une
embuscade ils ont capturé un soldat
russe je pense qu'ils vont le
[Musique]
tuer ils ont raison de le
tuer ça peut plus marcher ça vous
ralentit ils ont bien
fait Ariel et son groupe décident de
nous aider téléphone portable en main il
tente de joindre le commandant bravo
depuis plus d'un mois il est
introuvable moi je ne sais pas où est
son camp en ce moment j étis le mois
dernier mais depuis son camp a été
complètement détruit par les
militaires
bonjour d'accord c'est Dieu le Ve Bravo
est localisé l'accord est
donné faudra marcher toute la
nuit marcher toute la nuit c'est pas un
problème vous êtes prêt à marcher
donc il faut partir tout de suite en
pleine nuit nos étudiants se
transforment alors en vrai
combattant tiens passe-moi ton arme et
prends celle-là
les zones que nous allons franchir ne
sont pas sous leur contrôle c'est le
fief d'anciens Rebell devenus des
spécialistes de la prise d'otage même
GUID ne sont pas rassur vous AZ
[Applaudissements]
pe à partir de cet instant et jusqu'à
notre destination finale pour des
raisons de sécurité notre caméra doit
disparaître
au petit matin nous arrivons au lieu de
rendez-vous un camp improvisé au cœur de
la jungle protégé par ses soldats le
commandant bravo se prépare à la prière
pour lui parler il faudra attendre
depuis son passage en Afghanistan au
côté de Ben Laden rien ne peut
l'empêcher d'effectuer ces cinq prières
quotidiennes formé à la guerre sainte il
est devenu un combattant de l'islam même
à l'intérieur de la mosquée ces hommes
ne se séparent jamais de leurs
armes Allah a dit que les chrétiens
étaient des moins que rien et qu'il ne
les aimaient
pas nous sommes ici pour nous protéger
de nos
ennemis nous devonsfendre
nous allons
disparaître si votre sang coule dans
l'au-delà il se transformera en
miel celui qui meurt au combat Dieu le
récompensera la défense de l'islam
l'unité des musulmans contre les
infidèles voilà les raisons qui l'ont
poussé à partir en
Afghanistan je suis allé en Afghanistan
en passant par D en
Inde de Mani en Thaïlande un avion
jusqu'en
Inde d'ind au Pakistan puis la frontière
afghane c'est comme ça qu'on s'est
rencontré avec Ben
Laden comme lui je n'aime pas les
Américains et si j'en vois un je le
tue Ben Laden n'est pas un
terroriste les terroristes ce sont les
Américains
parce qu'ils ont bombardé l'IRAC la
Palestine le Soudan et l'Afghanistan
alors pourquoi ce sont pas les
Américains les
terroristes après l'enseignement du
Coran les hommes se regroupe le
commandant bravo une vraie discipline
militaire moitié d'entre eux sont des
combattants chevronnés certains sont
depuis plus de 20 ans dans le
Maqui moi je me suis entraîné à
l'étranger pendant 2 ans en
Afghanistan ce que j'ai appris là-bas je
l'enseigne maintenant ici à mes
hommes l'art de la Guera il ne
l'enseigne pas seulement aux adultes
c'est lui qui s'occupe personnellement
des plus
jeunes allez les jeunes on va
s'entraîner
certains ont à peine 10 ans il leur
parle déjà comme de vrais guerriers en
permanence il le incul la haine de
l'Amérique les autres mouvs Reb les
autres
pays il les Américains il courb les
chines
jamaisous plus for
nous nous sommes les soldats d'All il
n'y a pas d'autre pouvoir que le pouvoir
de
Dieu 3 4 5 6 à partir d'ici vous êtes le
groupe d' la formation va séparer en dez
on
y regardez aessus de
vous
équipe d'assut à
vous pour moi pas de
retite c'est mon style mon style pas de
retraite on ne se rend
pas
jamais pour nous c'est obligatoire
chaque soldat chaque musulman doit se
préparer à mourir en
martyre Allah a dit dans le Coran les
musulmans vont
gagner la nuit tombe bravo et sa garde
de jeunes soldats disparaissent les
enfants répétant les paroles du chef pas
de
retraite on ne se rend
pas
le combattant bravo ne dort jamais de
fois au même endroit nous reverrons pas
avant le lendemain matin il réapparaî au
sommet d'une colline audessus d'un
[Musique]
village vous regardez
quoi je regarde si je vois mes
ennemis
le gouvernement
philippin a offert une récompense de
500000 dollars à toute personnes pouvant
identifier l'endroit où je me
trouve les militaires veulent t'attraper
bravo même si un jour on signe la paix
ils s'en
foutent ils veulent m'attraper moi je ne
fais que me
[Musique]
protéger c'est mon territoire
dans le village les femmes s'affair le
commandant est ici chez lui et la
population tient à lui rendre hommage
aujourd'hui tous ces soldats vont faire
un vrai
repas regardez dans l'assiette c'est de
la bonne
nourriture voyez C civil c'est comme ma
famille il m'aime
personne ne les
force on ne les oblige pas à nous
nourrir ils nous soutiennent juste à
cause de
l'Islam juste à cause de
l'Islam après le repas comme un vrai
chef d'État il reçoit les doléances de
la population il est le seul maître sur
ce
territoire moi j'ai un problème mon fils
c'est recherché par le gouvernement on
l'accuse de
meurtre ne t'inquiète pas si ton fils a
des ennuis je le prends avec moi dans la
rébellion et voilà comment on récupère
un nouveau soldat avec lui ils vont tous
s'enfoncer dans la jungle le commandant
bravo retourne vers son camp principal
le camp
Aboubakar ce sera sans nous bravo ne
souhaite plus notre
présence
venez on va s'asseoir ici petite
explication avant de nous laisser partir
les autorités Philippines et américaines
l'accusent d'héberger dans sa base près
de 600 combattants étrangers ce sont eux
qui refusent catégoriquement d'être
filmés il y a des étrangers des
musulmans qui viennent pour s'entraîner
ils viennent ici à Mindanao dans notre
camp
Aboubakar ces musulmans venus d'autres
pays viennent ici pour des stages
et pour se battre aussi à nos
côtés lorsqu'il était en Afghanistan le
commandant bravo a été accueilli à bras
ouverts par les combattants d'alqaïda
aujourd'hui c'est à son tour d'offrir un
refuge à ses frères d'armes pour lui
cela s'appelle tout simplement
l'hospitalité